all right everyone hello welcome to pi
data global 2021 i'm florian i'm the
moderator for this session
and with me today we have paco nathan
who is going to be talking about graph
thinking
so paco is a managing partner at darwin
and lee committed to pytax rank and ke
glab
with core expertise in data science
natural language cloud computing and
roughly 40 years of tech in industry
experience that's impressive
ranging from bell labs to early
early stage startups he was an advisor
for amplify partners
recognize
as well as being a director
at community and community of community
evangelism at databricks and apache
spark
so without further mumbling on my side
i hand over to you
and everybody enjoy the talk
uh yes very grateful to present here and
the title is graph thinking
the slides are all online this is
talking about open source
and actually the slides have a lot of
links out to primary sources and
different tutorials and videos and
whatnot so
i i try to err on the side of having too
many links in the slides
so hopefully that can be a
resource uh
and just as far as who i am uh
you know i made the mistake of studying
ai
uh many years ago and uh against all
warnings and uh you know the lesson is
that if you really like something stick
with it for 30 or 40 years it'll
probably become very useful
i did have some great opportunities
along the way i got to be a guinea pig
for something new that was being
launched called aws
and i got to work a lot on on some of
the services like elastic mapreduce um
and uh also i i
as chloe mentioned i i had been uh
databricks some years ago back during
the hybrid growth period got to be a
community evangelist for apache spark
i've been involved in a lot of
conferences too like triple con and
strata data and other conferences now
more in the graph space
and speaking of that here's a link to
some conferences both recent and coming
up
but i'd like to talk about graph
thinking and this is about how to
leverage graph technologies especially
in the context of
python pi data stack if you will
but first off people ask well why would
i want to be doing graph technologies
what's what's the big deal why is this
useful
and so let me give a little bit of a
story here just briefly uh imagine that
we're somewhere in the woods and in fact
to make this a little bit more
interesting let's say we're in a
medieval village somewhere in the black
forest
and i i do a lot of work with colleagues
in germany not too far away from the
black forest
um
okay so in this village there's a pub
pat tends the pub and pat has a couple
of friends hannah and thomas
[Music]
and then hannah works the fields grows
the grain and has another friend aiden
thomas raises poultry buys grain from
hannah
and has another friend brenda
aiden works the mill so you know buys
the grand from hana
and has a friend named chris
brenda works the brewery brenda buys
grain from hana and produces beer has a
friend named kim
chris works the bakery chris buys eggs
from thomas and flour from iden makes
bread to sell back to pat
and then kim
works the recyclery
and kim buys organic waste from brenda
and thomas
uh and huh and then provides fertilizer
for hana
and so here you can see in the context
of a small village
seven businesses let's say there are
these relationships between the
businesses who is friends with whom
who sells to whom what do they sell
what do they consume and so we have a
graph
and it's describing really a circular
economy for this little village
now if we were to take and represent
this in terms of a relational database
you'd get something like this when you
when you get to normal form
you know you would you would have your
normalization with your your keys and
whatnot and i've got an erd over on the
side
and that's well and proper for being
able to do sql queries but as far as a
domain expert being able to understand
the patterns that are going on in the
relationships in this village it totally
tears that apart it's very difficult to
see these patterns once you've
normalized for
sql query optimization
but when you have a complex
context these kind of network views
instead are a way of bringing the data
closer to people who can really make
sense of it especially the people who
have the domain expertise they tend to
have more intuitive grasp of these kinds
of network views and
that acknowledges a few things one is
the context has a lot of complexity in
it
two is there are emergent patterns and
then three we need to be able to make
informed decisions by perceiving those
patterns
and those assumptions are a bit
different than what we would typically
see in like business intelligence based
on sql
so thinking about patterns here's an
example
let's say that hana is relatively new to
the village she'd like to expand her
business she's noticed that brenda is a
good customer buys a lot of grain
who are the other villagers who are
similar to brenda
so by leveraging graph technologies we
can go out and see
that chris also similarly sells product
to pat
sells waste to kim
and so that brings up the question could
the bakery
be using unmilled grain directly maybe
they would make mulch
and so maybe chris is a customer
prospect
and another kind of pattern you see in
graphs is who are the customers my
customers
and you can imagine that
while this could be done with a query in
a database a sql query if you're looking
3 4 5
10 20 hops out this becomes a very
complex kind of problem
and it's much more amenable toward graph
algorithms so for instance here chris
pat and kim are each a minimum two hops
away again chris is looking like a
pretty good customer prospect
and okay let's imagine that there's a
tech billionaire who uses time travel to
relocate back to medieval village in the
black forest
and uh you know this billionaire wants
to acquire the most influential
businesses
uh who are the best acquisition targets
well if you were to run a graph
algorithm called betweenness centrality
based on just this simple data you can
see that hana is really clearly one of
the most central uh characters in this
whole village
in terms of the business flows chris is
a second one in terms of ranking for
centrality
and of course as we get much larger
graphs
this is less obvious just to a casual
viewer but very easy to pull out using
graph algorithms
now i want to shift over and say
this idea of complexity and
understanding emergent patterns is very
important
um there's if you've ever heard the term
no knowns or unknown unknowns and some
unfortunate uses of them
uh
it really that goes back to uh dave
snowden who was at ibm back in the 90s
came out with something called kinevin
and it was a framework for decision
making and of course when we're working
in data science we are supporting
decision making
so what they said with kinevin was
there's
four contexts simple is one kind of
context where you have established facts
you just categorize the needs you apply
the rules the best practices and you
know
an untrained worker can do this
then there's a more complicated kind of
context where
it's not something that you can solve
with just best practices instead you
have to have somebody going and do
analysis
and then expert analysis leads to
assessing the facts coming up with a
response that leaders take
but then you can get into a complex
business scenario where best practices
don't work there's no simple answer you
must probe the situation you must sense
the patterns and make an informed
decision based off of these patterns
and this is where businesses tend to
fall apart because they they often will
use
analysis tools data analysis tools that
are based on a simple context or maybe a
complicated context but does not provide
affordances for a complex context
and as a leader when you apply overly
simplified approaches to a complex
problem
you end up with much bigger problems and
of course in the world today we see very
complex global problems like global
pandemics global supply chain
uh global climate crisis uh many things
that are very complex and must we must
be grappling with in terms of data
also though
in terms of pedagogy and learning theory
there's a very very similar kind of
effect
we see that when we're teaching novices
people when they're first learning a
subject they start out by having
some small facts that they're learning
memorizing
memoizing if you will
and these are typically disconnected
facts as people progress and become more
advanced they tend to start to chain
these facts together
and then when people become more
competent practitioners they tend to you
know become a walking decision tree
they come up with rural hierarchies and
are able to make decisions based off of
these kinds of like i say decision tree
structures which they have cognitively
but then when you move into being an
expert in a field you learn how to break
those rules you learn where are the
exceptions and the cognitive structures
that you develop are graphs
and this should be a very good clue
going forward in terms of guiding ai
that when people acquire expertise they
are doing internal modeling based on
graphs
so these things align how do business
leaders handle complex situations how do
people gather expertise from a cognitive
psychology standpoint and how do we
calculate things with data these are all
sort of aligning pointing toward
opportunities for leveraging graph
patterns especially in 21st century
kinds of problems
now there's a related thing that's very
important it's called ambiguity aversion
this comes out of cognitive psychology
also behavioral economics
and the idea is that a lot of people
when they're faced with complexity and
uncertainty they tend to want to avoid
it and move away towards something
that's much simpler
and unfortunately again when you apply
overly simplified approaches to a
complex situation you end up with even
bigger problems
um so i've linked that here there's some
great talks
uh there's one especially on tour data
science going over ambiguity your
version
and i i want to shout out uh a good
friend and colleague uh jurgen mueller
at bsf jurgen and i've put together a
lot of these materials he really gets
credit for a lot of this about the
village
but there's some more if you want to go
into detail on it
so now let me talk a bit more about
graphs before i start into the open
source side
when we talk about graphs usually we
have entities we have relations between
the entities there are different
attributes on these
in terms of
some types of graph work we have
controlled vocabularies that we use to
describe our shared definitions
and so these are these are kind of
schema that's overlaid on the graph
and frankly if you've ever worked with
object-oriented programming like in
python if you're familiar with working
with class hierarchies none of this
should be unfamiliar there's a lot of
correspondence between what we do with
graphs and controls vocabularies and
what people do when they're programming
with class hierarchies
now in the graph space there's a couple
different prevailing views one is
the the semantic web w3c kinds of
technologies and these are great for a
lot of applications
um but then there's also the property
graphs labeled property graphs which are
more popular in the graph databases
and there is work in progress to align
these two it is possible i can verify
that it's possible to have a labeled
property graph with the rdf overlay
so there's really nothing stopping using
both of these
however you know when we look
i'm involved with a community that's
called knowledgecraft conference
and i've been curating up a list of
public lists please add to it if you
want
but we're tracking at least 40 different
graph database vendors currently
but yet when we look at the large
industry use cases they're really more
concerned with scalable graph compute
not with database i mean frankly
enterprise firms already have sap and
oracle and all that
and and really this recalls the scenario
of the mid 2010s when there are a whole
bunch of mpp vendors out there all based
on hadoop during distributed sql and
then spark came along and said well
actually your problem is about scalable
compute not so much database features
and so i i think they were kind of at
that sort of nexus again
we'll probably see a lot more push
toward horizontal scale out and compute
as and less and less about
graph databases
the other thing that's going on of
course is graph neural networks
we've seen some really fascinating work
over the past
five years or so
in terms of being able to represent
graph problems with deep learning uh
either by doing embeddings or even more
directly by doing graph neural networks
and there's an emerging term called
geometric deep learning uh i really
would point towards some people like
michael brunstein and masse vesta
there's great projects like pytorch
geometric graph gym out of stanford and
snap
and and this is a way of sort of
blending between domain expertise being
represented in graphs and ai
applications that leverage deep learning
also primary sources there's a really
great history of this by uh claudio
gutierrez and once again recently uh and
also just going back the foundational
paper of course was natasha noah and
deborah mcginnis 2001 and even going
back into the 19th century charles purse
had references to knowledge graphs back
then
so real quick let's talk about the
business side
a lot of people when they talk about
data they think about tables they think
about rows and columns tabular tabular
representation spreadsheets
realistically though when you're working
with spreadsheets when you're working
with sql they have graphs embedded in
them
spreadsheets have dependency graphs sql
queries all have complex query plans
that are dags
now a problem is that if you are working
with graph you're working with a complex
scenario and you try to overly simplify
it you end up creating tech debt and so
we see this with spreadsheets i will
shout out to uh a friend fellaini herman
in netherlands who did her phd about
spreadsheets and just how much tech debt
is looming out there
um and so it's really interesting that
over the past year there's been a real
mind shift gartner in 2020 was saying
that graphs you know whatever
and then in february they did an about
face and they said well we're at about
10 penetration for uh graph technologies
and analytics right now but we estimate
that by 2025 we'll see 80 percent of
graph and data analytics will be using
graphs or data analytics with using
graphs and currently about at least 50
percent of their inquiries about ai are
regarding graph technologies
so gardner is pushing that graphs have
have reached a turning point
and and part of that is this
allow you to expose metadata and
business rules and a lot of this is
typically swept under the rug and that
leads to problems like compliance gdpr
other kinds of risks
definitely tucked up
so i wanted to share um you know i think
a lot of people hear graph and they
think oh that's just like large social
graph at the big tech giants it's not
true um there's actually the the big
verticals that we see are in finance
pharma and manufacturing they tend to
have advanced graph practices
um you know and the typical kind of
problems you're dealing with are like
data integration across business silos
uh being able to recognize patterns in
terms of shapes or motifs grappling with
complexity uncertainty that would be
very difficult to manage in a relational
database
uh np hard problems like disambiguation
and and places where details zooming
into details is more important than say
aggregate counts like you would do in a
lot of data science
so some examples i'll definitely point
um albert laszlo barabasi is doing
fantastic work with network medicine
uh definitely in drug discovery you see
novartis and astrazeneca i think that
stefan reilling's work uh some of his
talks about using graphs for novartis
are really astounding definitely we see
this in siemens and bosch and basf and
others in manufacturing um
jin luna dong has some great talks out
of amazon with the product graph
on and on uh definitely refinitive in
bloomberg and others in the fintech
space
and there's some links there to some
references about them
another area is climate science i work
with a really interesting group in the
u.s the three agencies that are involved
with climate science have what they call
the earth observatory that's nasa usgs
and noaa and they're doing a lot of work
with large-scale graphs
okay so
uh
one other part that's important is a
little bit of graph theory
there is an area that we have called
algebraic graph theory where we can
transform from a graph into a matrix or
a vector or a tensor
and that leads to something that's
called non-negative matrix factorization
it's been used a lot
they're really fantastic resources for
this but it's not the only trick
sometimes what you need to do is blend
both symbolic representation and numeric
representation because you know there
are things that leverage numeric
representation deep learning is one of
them but other things require the
symbolic part especially when you have
explainable machine learning models
uh and so i i i tried to grapple with
with exploring this topic
and i came out with uh something called
you know thinking spartan dance with
with apologies to daniel kahneman
um
but there are certainly types of data
science work that require more sparta
sparse approaches you see this typically
like in data preparation
these are generally bandwidth limited
whereas you see other parts of data
science machine learning workflows if
you will
that are dense where they're typically
compute limited like you know training
stages of a pipeline
um so there's a a free download if you
want there's a mini book that dean
wampler and i did called hardware's
greater than the software greater than
process and we did this with nvidia
recently with some of their open source
leads from rapids
and and this is related to a kind of
general view of data science is that you
know typically we're managing
dimensionality
you know we started with with a lot of
very sparse unruly data very
unstructured and then we move through
pipelines we progress more and more
towards structure
and that's a lot of what we tend to do
in data science is i think a lot of the
random reasons and it's really
leveraging this trade-off between
symbolic and numeric representation at
different points
so that's kind of the thesis for say
graph data science if you will
so uh i want to mention about a project
we have called kglab this has been going
on since last october so about a year
and the idea is that we wanted to
explore graph data science
ai workloads often require complex
graphs especially for data integration
but basically preparing data we want to
train in in machine learning models
and a lot of the the different camps in
the graph technology space they're very
balkanized uh they don't talk with each
other a lot of the stuff out of the w3c
stack i mean some of that stuff was
started back in the late 90s you know
and the code is really really awful
um so we wanted to have a way to
basically
bring these different camps together and
make them very pythonic make them work
with pi data technologies so if you're
working in pandas and it's like it learn
and ask can you then go out and use
things like network x and pi shackle and
and
you know
psl
which otherwise wouldn't have a really
clear integration path
so we've been working on our team has
been working on an open source project
uh it's gain some popularity
it's an abstraction layer in python to
bring in these different kinds of graph
technologies and blend them in with the
pi data stack
and it's really taking your mind toward
how can we leverage a lot of good
distributed systems infrastructure like
das and rapids and and leveraging arrow
ray spark and then looking forward
toward things like league
and just to show you what's going on
here uh you know we have definitely
provisions we leverage a lot of rdf libs
so if you want to construct a graph
using triples
you know this is very well defined
in kg lab you define a namespace you
create an object and you start adding
triples to it
if you want to be using different
serialization formats to import large
data sets uh we've integrated for all of
the w3c formats
um but then also for json ld
so we have a lot of different ways to
bring in different kinds of data frankly
what we've and actually there's even
more obscure ways if you want to work
with dodd or yaml or you know graphic
mail things like that
um one of the more interesting areas of
this is actually being able to import
from rome research
because those are inherently graphs as
well
but what we're finding though is that
park a using arrow
using part k is the most efficient for
serialization with large graphs and
graph data or even small graph data and
i mean it's orders of magnitude more
effective than using other formats and
it's also native for things like spark
and trino and cassandra
um
in terms of visualizations you know it's
really nice to be able to pull in a
bunch of different data into a graph run
some graph algorithms and get some
visualizations and previously there
weren't a lot of good integration
passwords so now
you know once you've got your graph
built and you've run some processing
with graph algorithms maybe you want to
go visualize by using something like pi
biz or cairo
graphistry is another one that i really
really love to use
and if you want to run queries there's
support for using sparkle so uh you know
you run a sparkle query through it but
you get an iterator with name name
tuples or a pandas data frame as the
output again trying to really make this
fit well
and by the way for each of these
different areas of technology i'm trying
to link in playgrounds in in the graph
space we often have something called a
playground where you can go and and try
out some queries or try to work with
some data just in a small constraint
environment
um there's also really great in work in
terms of validation and prescription
it's kind of like building unit tests
but it's something more recent called
shackle that allows you to have shape
constraints
um and so this way you can sort of apply
test to a graph
and then there's a wide range of graph
algorithms i love using kugraf from
nvidia also network x and igraph there's
a lot of different work going on there
in this space
and of course the big news is with graph
neural networks and leveraging embedding
um so you know we've got some tutorials
that show how to do all these kinds of
stages we've got a progressive example
that we're using from datafromfood.com
out of a kaggle data set
and the other one that i really like
that's a little bit more obscure is
something called psl this allows you to
work with uncertainty and apply
probabilistic rules to a graph and be
able to test it for for certainty this
is an area of something called
statistical relational learning and uh
and it works really well when blended
with these other technologies so we're
bringing that into python
and what i want to show here is there's
many different angles about inference
you can be assuming it's very strict and
axiomatic you can be doing something
that's very loosey-goosey like graph
embedding graphical networks
there's a lot of points in between how
can we mix and match and build pipelines
that are basically hybrid ai that
combine different parts of these and put
them together
and so we have this project called kg
lab again it's an abstraction layer for
this
and
one of the kinds of applications is in
nlp a lot of nlp natural language
understanding is essentially taking text
to construct graphs
and then there's a project called pi
text rank that uses
a very efficient entity extraction from
graphs based off of text wraps
um i'm running out of time so i want to
go to some questions uh if you want to
get a hold of me i'm on twitter at
pocaloid and uh i look forward to
talking with you um thank you very much
thank you paco for this excellent
talk
um so we have a question from uh phillip
i i don't know if you can hear me hi
yeah yes
determining factor yeah there we go
um
uh so
most of the time when i see graph
problems in the wild or in my experience
they are modeling a single relationship
a bunch a bunch of different entities
rather than a diversity of
relationships um that you might see in
the setting like modeling ecological
systems yeah um
do
are there
strategies or technologies or is this a
a different type of graph problem than
what would be addressed through these
libraries
you know this is a really good point i
mean especially if you're using network
x it's sort of dictionary dictionaries
um if using network x or using tools
like pi biz they really oversimplify the
graph relationships uh such that you
just have this sort of edge
representation and they they throw away
a lot of the relationship info
um so a lot of the n tools when you're
doing a particular thing will actually
throw away and that was part of my
argument about how in algebraic graph
theory you have these transforms from a
graph into say a tensor or matrix
part of the problem with converting a
graph to a matrix is you throw away
information like this
so yes if you're using rdf lib um you
can have a lot of complex uh types of
relationships modeled and then what
we're doing in kg lab is we have a
consistent way of doing transforms and
inverse transforms similar like in in
scikit-learn where you have uh
transforms for labels
um and so that way you can have your
data and then pull a subset of it
transform it into a dance representation
crunch it in network x and then bring it
back bring the results back into a much
more richer space that's that's not
compacted but the computation is
typically done on a single relation
structure
not not necessarily no i mean you can
you can pull a subset and then represent
these in different ways um so no that
the
there are there are better ways i mean
again you know kind of looking at some
of the earlier uh graph approaches
especially when things were very much
focused on non-negative matrix
factorization
it was really difficult to have multiple
kinds of relationships modeled
because very quickly you get into
requiring tensors not matrices
but these days it turns out you know i
mean when i was teaching this stuff in
2014 i would mention graphs and half the
class would run screaming the opposite
direction and then i would say but a
graph is really a tensor and then like
the entire class would empty out um but
you know shortly either thereafter
sorry guys
yes i hate to interrupt this uh this
fantastic conversation but we have run
out of time
all right thank you so much and uh yeah
have a nice rest of the conference okay
thank you thank you